ps5 box contents may have been revealed
those bungie and microsoft acquisition
rumors have been debunked
and halo 3 odst is releasing on pc
this month i'm persia and you've reached
your safe state for monday september
14th
[Music]
there is a ps5 showcase coming up in a
couple of days
but ahead of that the box contents for
sony's next-gen console
have seemingly been revealed despite the
console
not having a release date or a price
right now
according to nico partners senior
analyst daniel ahmad
the boxes for both the digital and
standard editions of the playstation 5
feature the same things alongside the
console and wireless dual synth
controller
you get the attachable base an ac power
cord hdmi cable
and more the attachable base means
you'll be able to turn the console on
its side
out of the box whereas the ps4 requires
the stand as a separate purchase to
properly
place the console vertically it isn't
possible to place the ps5 horizontally
without the stand because of its form
factor which has
curves on both sides astros playroom
will also come pre-installed on both
consoles but might need an
update when you get it if you want to
stay up to date on the upcoming ps5
showcase then
of course be sure to tune in to
gamespot.com
talks of microsoft potentially acquiring
bungie
are circulating but they aren't true
according to bungie
venture beats jeff grubb recently
discussed the rumor that
microsoft and bungie were in discussions
but the two companies couldn't land on a
price
this was later corroborated by eurogamer
however the ceo of bungie pete parsons
kept it short and sweet when he took to
twitter to declare the news as false
along with dj from bungie's community
team requesting that people use bungie's
new logo
when circulating gossip about the
company bungie recently left a
publishing deal with activision ending a
10-year partnership
earlier than expected and is currently
independent
and it looks to be staying that way for
now
finally halo 3 odst is arriving on pc
on september 22nd as part of halo the
master chief collection
both the campaign and firefight the wave
based survival mode
are heading to pc for the very first
time following a recent beta period
odst's description on xbox game pass
says firefight is joining the master
chief collection
on console and pc for the first time
with online matchmaking
dedicated servers and new custom game
modes
this inclusion could imply that
firefight is also coming to xbox one on
september 22nd
but it's not an explicit confirmation so
we'll just have to wait and see
that is all for today i hope the start
of your week has been awesome
and don't forget to meet us back here
tomorrow for your next save state
see you later
you